president trump is back he is
demonstrating in his words
and in public opinion polls that
the gop is still the trump party and cnn
is ecstatically furious
this cpac with donald trump closing it
out is a
liar palooza uh it's a liar palooza
zing yeah take that trump yeah you're a
big meanie yeah it's a
liar festa this was the best
day that jim acosta has had in months
jim acosta has gone
to his bed every single night since
trump conceded the election
and he's written dear diary it's another
it's another sad day here in the acosta
household i miss him
i have nothing to talk about no one
wants to put me on television anymore
no one gives me headlines because my man
is gone
well trump is back and the
media are are furious so
trump's cpac speech was generally more
measured than some people said it would
be and some people said he was going to
announce a new political party
some people said he was going to declare
himself the nominee for 2024 some people
said he was going to do all this
it was actually much more measured he
he reigned himself in a little bit but
he still talked about the important
issues starting most importantly
with election integrity another one of
the most
urgent issues facing the republican
party
is that of ensuring fair honest
and secure elections
[Music]
such a disgrace we must pass
comprehensive election reforms and we
must do
it now the democrats used the china
virus
as an excuse to change all of the
election rules without the approval of
their state legislatures
making it therefore illegal
it had a massive impact on the election
again you have to go to the legislatures
to get these approvals
this alone would have easily changed the
outcome of the election
at levels that you wouldn't have even
believed
now people are going to be very upset
trump is pushing a lie about the
election show me the lie
where's the lie the democratic election
officials
exploited the china virus to upend the
election systems in the weeks and months
before the election often without
the approval of state legislatures in
some cases in direct violation
of the state constitutions so
show me the lie i don't see a lie there
but then notice what trump says he
doesn't say and that's why we actually
won the election and biden 100
actually lost he didn't say that he said
it had a massive
impact on the election which is true you
you can
least say even if you think that the
whole rigging of the election systems
was illegitimate and terrible you still
can't say for with 100 certainty trump
won the election you know and
the votes that were fraudulent were
enough to sway the election
no one actually can say that people
might have a hunch they might have an
intuition
but you can't but you certainly can say
that
these election rules were upended in the
days and months right before the
election
and this did have an impact on the of
course you can say that so
trump holds himself there to me what
this means is
trump does not want to go out with a you
know
huge bang he doesn't want to go out you
know with fireworks
he wants to remain in the game and he's
willing to play in a certain sense by
the rules
so that he can have a big influence in
2022 and who knows
maybe 2024. trump also
in we'll get to 2024 in a second in
terms of 2022
he named names he went
after the squishy republicans who he
feels
are not standing up for what the
republican base wants
he didn't back off that he went this is
another reason he's not just playing
nice
and trying to have a nice legacy here he
is calling out the people that he wants
to boot out of office as soon as he can
now more than ever is the time for tough
strong and energetic
republican leaders who have spines of
steel we need strong leadership
top establishment republicans in
washington
should be spending their energy in
opposing biden pelosi schumer
and the democrats i've said to some of
them i said you know
during the obama years and now during
biden
if you spent the same energy on
attacking them you'd actually be
successful
as you do on attacking me in many cases
the democrats don't have grandstanders
like mitt romney
little ben sass richard burr bill
cassidy susan collins
lisa murkowski pat toomey david
valadeo and of course the war monger
a person that loves seeing our troops
fighting
liz cheney how about that
[Applause]
the good news is in her state she's been
censured and in her state
her poll numbers have dropped faster
than any human being i've ever seen
this is donald trump's party i say that
not just as someone who likes trump
when i when i say this is donald trump's
party i'm sort of pleased
that i can say that but even people who
hate trump's guts even romney and liz
cheney and all the rest of them
have to admit this is trump's party mitt
romney did admit it the other day he
said
i mitt romney represent a very small
sliver of the republican party donald
trump would win the nomination in a
landslide if he ran
how strange is it that at cpac this is
sort of the big
conservative conference of the year
the chairman of the house republican
caucus liz cheney
gets booed overwhelmingly booed on the
floor like that
mitt romney who won the cpac straw poll
in 2012
mitt romney who used to be pretty
popular at cpac getting booed
because the party is shifting and
because politics
always does change it changes according
to circumstance
so that's 2022 obviously i think trump
is going to try to pick off some of his
political opponents
but what about 2024 if trump's got the
party behind him if trump's got the
conservative base
behind him if trump's picking off his
opponents is he going to run in 2024
well he doesn't say no but who knows
who knows i may even decide
to beat them for a third time okay
that is a long long long round of
applause and standing ovation and trump
does it in the most trumpian way
with such a showman's flourish she goes
and look i may even you're kind of
leaning in look i might even
decide to beat him for a third time boom
and then the crowd
opens up and when he says beat him for a
third time he's obviously suggesting
this is this is the most i think trump
in his speech went to say
that election you know a lot of
irregularities a lot of irregularities
there
uh the the cpac straw poll is pretty
interesting
because in terms of the candidates
trump wins he walks away with it he got
the majority of votes
in a field of uh trump desantis gnome
haley pompeo
trump gets 55 percent in the sepak straw
poll
so even if all those other candidates
were just one other candidate
trump still wins uh desantis
no surprise there that he's coming up
second by a lot too it's 55
to 21 for desantis then when you get to
christy gnome
it's four percent nikki haley three
percent mike pompeo two percent
not really surprising numbers when you
take a look at the struggle without
trump so let's say trump decides not to
run
ron desantis still crushing it he's got
43 up there
christy nomen 11 don jr at 8
again just evidence that the trump
family is dominating the party even
don jr right who was not the president
still doing pretty well
pompeo seven percent cruz seven percent
the one thing worth noting here
is that the straw poll has a kind of 50
50 record so the straw poll was right
about the nominee
in uh 1980 and then obviously right in
1984
they probably shouldn't even held it
that year but reagan got it again in 84.
either right in 96 2000 or 2012. but the
cpac straw poll got the nominee wrong
in 76 92 2008 and 2016.
trump trump did not come in first or
even second in 2016.
so these things can change quite a lot
the other thing i would say about ron
desantis
he's doing a great job he's doing
everything he should be doing um
but it's a long time it's a long time
away from 2024
the the people who tend to win this
early historically have not
actually gotten the nomination later on
so we'll have to see more interesting
even than the candidates are the issues
the top issue for the cpac audience
election integrity followed by
constitutional rights followed by
immigration followed by reopening the
economy was pretty low on the list
followed by the second amendment
followed by taxes followed by national
security
finally followed by pro-life it's pretty
interesting i i don't think it's because
the
cpac crowd is pro-abortion now i suspect
it's just because
they feel that we're at a stalemate and
no matter how many judges we get we
still keep
losing they the issue here is the
corruption they feel
we keep winning these political battles
but we keep losing on these issues so
that's actually my read of why pro-life
is so down low it's people are very
demoralized
and i think it's why election integrity
is so high because they do not have
faith
in this system they don't really have
the sort of faith in the institutions
that we once had you've got to root out
the corruption before you can solve
these sorts
of problems i hope you enjoyed that clip
from the michael knowles show to check
out the full episode
hit the link in the description or
download the michael knowles show
wherever you listen to podcasts